foreign
I've never realized this entire time
you've always looked like a retired
strong man
I've thrown beer kegs over walls you go
you know he sets the record with the
boulder hold
bertrend Chrysler Von Kreischer yeah
by the way have you seen what is going
on in Philadelphia no the show go to
Just Google search Philadelphia fentanyl
I don't even know the name of the street
but there's a prominent Street in Philly
where people are nodding off on the side
of the road but that's every American
city no no this one's like crazy but
people are like halfway up like that guy
go down a little bit this one so this is
what everybody looks like now it's like
they're trying to suck their own dick
but they're trying to stay away you know
we should do when we're there fentanyl
yeah we're going to Philly
walking down the street we could do a
thriller thing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I don't know
cause this is
[Laughter]
I gotta tell you
it's terrible that's terrible it's
terrible there's a 911 documentary uh
it's like the best one it's it was on
the History Channel and it was uh it was
just footage it was just chronological
and it was home Home Videos yeah and one
of them is these students from NYU I've
seen that video
in the documentary they never showed
them drinking yeah
while
the tower the first plane's already
actually the second plane hit because
yeah they collapsed these kids are just
drinking beer like watching it
[Laughter]
it's a wild video what do we do a wild
video also if it's the same video it's
like 10 a.m too it's really early and
there's like glasses glasses again so
let's get a couple brewskies watch the
fire oh my God but they also if it's the
same video I'm thinking there were
people jumping oh and they were somebody
in the video they claimed there was no
jumpers pictures something of the Great
Depression
yeah they're like nobody actually jumped
I'm thinking of two different things
yeah there's like there's that famous
photo of the dude like head first yeah I
don't think he's ever been identified
probably not I mean jumped from falling
man up yeah true it's a scary bit dude
yeah no I mean you think somebody from
the picture would be like of the dead
people will be like that oh yeah that
looks like my husband what's the thought
behind that it's burned to death or
Splat yeah I think I think it was like
you couldn't breathe and what you were
holding on to was so hot you had to just
let go
or jump yeah I'll take the jump over the
burn to death yeah close dude I don't
know if I could get myself to jump you
would at least try your sneakers to grip
on the side see if you can just
[Laughter]
like one time one time
fire department was watching you guys
going thank you
he's gonna make it holy [__] he's gonna
do it oh nope he's off he's off
[Applause]
spit on your hands and wipe your shoes
it's like a basketball court
no that the jumpers was truly the most
haunting part of that entire it's
terrible the jumpers was the scariest
part by yeah I saw the video on Twitter
like two days ago from clips that go
hard
but we have an actual chance like it's
not out of the realm of possibility to
perform at like the real Madison Square
Garden sure it's not out of the realm of
possibility it's no it's like there's
people who are in line to do it all
three of us are but it's like as New
Yorkers it's like if that happens it's
almost like it's almost like if that
happens then like where'd he go from
there what do you do what are you even
what are you doing everything else is
just like all right yeah I think weird
sex stuff yeah that's what it is yeah
that's when you get into kids
that's true I mean look at Epstein he
had everything where do you go what's
your what's your uh because obviously
New York is where the garden but is it
Garden as well eight or nine-year-old
that sound we're talking about we're
talking full homosexuals so we need
someone who identifies as a man yep I'm
willing to [__] for science no dick
pills yeah you find somebody cute enough
that I approve if you're unwilling to
try and [__] them and we'll see if my
dick gets hard
[Laughter]
go down
email your picks to your mom's podcast
gmail.com now look I gotta approve them
right yes
we're gonna have more science they're
going to email you put stavi in the
subject line be hot be gay and be ready
to [__] all right but feminine no I'm
sorry fellas he doesn't want a Butchy
I'm sorry that's the kind look I we all
have our thing right you got to be like
uh I'm willing at least to get head at
least for a couple minutes to get my
dick sucked and like you really cute
guys
I'm gonna bust so fast I'm gonna just
like oh
how about this though but if I bust soft
fast yeah that's still that just means
I'm gay yes that doesn't mean your
theory on hard dicks yeah
you know like this good we could get a
really inconclusions there's gonna be no
winners here you know gay and my dick is
soft
I think the only thing you could do then
is just [__] more guys
I just marry that guy he has changed my
whole life oh [__]
happened to it dude let's do it let's do
it I'm a man of science first and
foremost yeah yeah let's get to the
bottom of this this is um this is gonna
happen
so your dick's never been soft huh Tom I
mean I've had a uh
never I'm telling you the guys
sure no no I've had some soft days of
course of course I've had days where I'm
like this is it yeah but you know like
for the most part I've been pretty yeah
I've been kind of soft with other guys
jump you look like a naked mole rat
[__] holy [__] this is like landlord on
tenant I've never seen this
this is not going to end well
we need to de-escalate it hey Dave you
look like you got your plumbing
certificate
if you're here who's who's working at
every Denny's everywhere all right
what'd you ask for a Denver omelette
when I'm ready when
anything playing with a child here
you're playing with it now
if Homeless was a video game you look
like the last [__] that got a battle to
get a tent
holy [__]
I heard I heard you just got a part in
that new movie wakanta now
meaning I can't walk up the steps now
sorry David tell I heard you doing home
alone on Ice [__]
hold into it Jeff get me out of this
no I bet you want to wear a do-rag get
your [__] Harley Davidson
driving ass about him boy Whoa
it's too far
I'm not wearing it well you got Jeff
Ross drawers on your head
oh my God
[Music]
this guy really came alive hey David too
I've only seen this at the counter at
Popeye's I mean honestly
that energy that commitment
hey Dave I need you to shave your beard
to give
eyebrows
that [__] up here looking like a
mannequin very nice that's not funny
because I have alopecia which I believe
is your aunt's name
[Music]
I'm gonna start to try to try to
practice
like
poverty once or twice a month what I
mean by that is not going crazy living
on the street what I mean by that is I'm
just to be more appreciative of what I
have is to go you know instead of
driving in because I have the luxury of
doing that in parking take the ferry
take the two buses sit coach flying to
you know a city
um um just to help appreciate because
then when I get the opportunity because
dude I just heard Chris talking about
this in the other room
I just walked in like Kramer
you just say you're gonna practice
poverty if I fly coach and ride in the
subway
you just described my regular life
poverty
[Laughter]
swear to God I was leaving
I was walking out the door right now and
as I was walking by I heard you say that
that's so crazy
that's so funny you just invited me to
see your house for the rest of my money
he he said that's one level above
homelessness
he's like not homeless but like I'll fly
coach I'll take the ferry he said
they could have examples I couldn't
think of anything I'll leave Joey roses
what you meant what you meant was that
well you you want to cut out daily
amenities yes I meant like you know like
you can apply it to whatever your life
is at home like you know practice
poverty
at three years old your parents split up
okay
they separated but still we're dealing
with each other off and on okay because
I know like five and six he was
definitely in and out yeah definitely
rare mornings and [__] you're like hey
what are you doing tonight yeah like
what's up man I thought you were gone
and did he stay in Houston though was he
just saying so he was close by oh yeah
he was he wasn't far because my every
birthday like from six to about
um I'm gonna give it about eight
I hated them birthdays because that's
what my dad would um try to use my
birthday party to get back on my mom you
know I was seeing dancing with her she
like
why are you why are you coming to my
birthday party you know you'll do that
with my sister like why are you using my
party you're watching your dad trying to
get laid at six is a tough one
just watching your dad strike out like
with a lady that he has two children
everybody pack it in yeah like everybody
is over
but he go all out for those birthdays
I'm talking about go all
[Laughter]
the priest gets angry he's like I
thought you said you were a virgin
dude priest I I the other day touched a
guy's head he like asked for absolution
because he was heckling and I touched
his head and I did I was like if this
was a little boy being like please
forgive me I did kind of get it
no dude
I'm gonna strike that from the record
I don't get it objection I don't your
honor I just couldn't get power over a
child I gotta understand me could you
say this I I touched a grown man when I
was in a position of power and I felt an
erotic thrill from it how about that how
if I was a grown-up and I was touching a
child I would feel the same way I'm more
was like who does that and I thought
priests and I went oh that's why they
[__] kids okay all right like I don't
know that you're how about this I don't
know that your logic was airtight on
that it's not airtight yeah but if um if
a man walks up to the stage he's about
child height and he says please forgive
me let's lose the whole child
let's just get you man that you can
legally have sex with you're in a
position of power over him and you touch
his head in a way that's gross
[Laughter]
if it was me good point and oh yeah that
was a good point
no it wasn't sure
I didn't have anything to do with the
[__]
they're awkward they're great nice dude
yeah okay nice I'm just saying I'm just
saying
there was somebody who was helpless
for the reason they're helpless but if
they were helpless say they're crippled
I guess that's an improvement oh yeah
entity and titty see the difference and
titty is so much fun you say tit or tits
do you say do you say do you say tits or
titty titties because I think I think
you really like I think I think people
latch on to one of those one of those
phrases like when you're referring to
breasts of of the female variety are you
saying oh it's a nice tits it was a nice
tit that's a knife our tit fell out by
accident uh it was a nipples or do you
say she's got more examples please I'm
not catching the concept
like it's 1984. uh I I'd say tit I never
ever
say titties say titties or titties
such a funny one it's the trashiest
grossest way to say it it makes me sick
I have I have friends that exclusively
say it that way I think less of them I
think both of them are like arguably two
of the most funny words in the in the
language of art but I have friends that
say it that's just their word
Big Jay oakerson and he's public about
this I'm not talking high school he says
like titties and I'm like what are you a
porn photographer in the valley like
what is wrong with you like it's such a
it's so gross I don't think titties is
in the dictionary I don't think titty is
because I tried uh I tried titty on
world it was like uh no no no no
spelling bee I'm spelling bee and it
didn't come out nobody said titties
since the editor of Swank magazine like
you know what I mean like some guy with
DeStefano glasses on
behind a desk with like those Boss Hog
horns
[Music]
I am in the titty business
got that part of that that uh we were
talking last night on stage about that
um nude beach in Perth yeah so there's
also all these it's a movie so you go
because first of all you do hear when
you get like you want to go to the nude
beach yeah and you're like always you
love to be naked I love it yeah so yeah
without any like judgment absolutely
let's go and it's a beach you know sure
West face facing Beach nice Beach nice
Beach really wide lots of sand with
Dunes like in the back
um hotties everywhere no old gays yeah
yeah yeah just very old leering gays
like I told just like come right next to
you like there's so much space bro yeah
and like yeah I'm gonna check out what
you got yeah
so Nick Cody told me this that in the
dunes
when they're like when you do walk by
somebody and like you get a response I'm
sure they must look to me like nothing
back yeah yeah like I'm just here to air
out my dick yeah but uh once you find a
guy you like you're like let's go [__]
so you go to the dunes with all these
little Pathways and stuff and yeah
you're [__] back there the dunes is
also connected to where the military
tests their artillery Jesus so
somebody's job in the military was to go
through Dunes say stop [__] we're
about to test let's get out of here stop
[__] I thought you were gonna say
it's somebody's job to kill games
come on GO train wait till it's full and
then pull the trigger and the kid's like
should we get out here like oh [__] just
[__] quietly if your dad if your
biological dad asks for money would you
give up to him no why would I give him
money no no just he's calling you yeah
what's his can I just say Bob all right
I don't want to say it on that I'll say
it backwards Bob okay
it's your dad Bob what do you say is
your dad no it's Bob hey it's Bob
um I'm in a pinch
and son I know that you're doing well
you know um I need five grand in a jiffy
or you know I'm gonna get evicted would
you do it
maybe I think you would if it's about
being evicted yeah probably now your
half brother calls you've never met him
before yeah I know I don't know you but
I'm in a pinch I need five grand at this
rate I'm gonna be [__] broke I keep
bringing people out of my life what is
this yeah I would probably I would do it
I I hope he's not [__] listening yeah
yeah
everything you get to Is Not What It
Seems nothing is what it seems I've
never been to Disney World but I think
that that's it would be exactly what I
expected with a child it's amazing right
but when adults go just alone I'm always
confused yeah you can't go you should
not go especially with the way that your
gate The Way You Walk no chance I know
they'll figure you out real fast they'll
also sniff that I'm part Mexican and
I'll be out they're like are you not on
the job today if you're gay and you're
at Disney World you're either playing a
prince
or you're arrested
only part of vanity that makes you want
to be skinnier in shape is so you can
feel better when someone else sees you
right you don't really give a [__] right
I don't really care if I'm in good shape
right I want someone else to go yeah you
look good right that's it that's why gay
guys take care of themselves so well
better than anybody I've ever seen
because they got a little kind of
chickish vibe about like I got these two
buddies that are that that they you they
have the same like they have a skin care
routine that he said he wanted to put me
on yeah and they both these guys look
like they're you know 24 years old
they're 40. and but they're also happy
so they don't have sad lines right like
you have sad lines you have sad lines
right we've it's hit us it's it it's hit
us reality is reality is to beat the
[__] off yeah it's really instead of
dicks in my face it's pain and sadness
if a couple of dicks hit you might smile
more dude it's happier my brother's gay
it's a happy existence
he goes to [__] Portugal he goes to
Greece he's having a great nobody goes
to Portugal and Greece yeah yeah you
already said he was gay
yeah that's like Israel they give you a
ticket when you're gay to go to Portugal
it's personal right for a gay guy is it
going to south of Spain yeah they send
you a ticket in the mail we heard you
were gay one free trip to Portugal and
the Sabbath it comes with it yeah yeah
it's a part of the deal that's part of
the gig you know when I worked with the
children who had autism dude I almost
felt like they're so smart and they're
operating at such a different wavelength
that it's not so much that wait why'd
you work with the kids with autism oh
because Physical Therapy it out of them
no no I tried I'm about dodgeball and
just let one rip
I know you're faking it you got all
different kinds of kids you got kids
with cerebral palsy so those you know
there's a girl in there
second day on the job this principal
calls me to the office she goes Chris
how's everything I was like it's good
I'm loving it having fun she goes it's
great because we're having a good time
because I just have to remind you again
you cannot run up and down the hallways
with the kids holding them like
footballs you're not allowed to do that
and then Spike them into bean bags
because I was the only male that's a
very female oriented profession yeah so
I was the only guy I was the only guy
there so I mean I was having so much fun
with these kids but she was like again
you know they some of these kids are
feeding tubes they have issues and
you're having a good time and we're but
it's a liability
at joke world
and that world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out